I've never heard of a cattle prod.
There are stories of back
rooms without cameras
where guys get roughed up a little bit.
Nowadays, we don't need to do that.
Hello, everybody. My name's Brian Stanton.
I'm a casino executive in Las
Vegas for Station Casinos.
I have 20 years in the
table-games business
watching and looking at game security.
Today, we're going to be looking at
casino-heist movie scenes
and judge how real they are.
Whoo! You are a winner!
Inside jobs, collusion is
a thing that we worry about
and a thing that we look into.
There's been numerous stories of dealers
setting up bets that aren't there
or paying bets that aren't there,
because they're in
collusion with a player.
Things they're doing stand out.
So, when I'm walking the floor,
if I see dealers turning their head
and looking where I'm at or
where their supervisor's at,
they want to know where we're at
because something's going on.
Security measures.
When the system senses a threat,
it shuts down and reboots.
Well, for how long?
Man: Three minutes and 20 seconds.
I've been in a few older properties
where something will happen
with a power transformer.
Power goes out in the city.
If we lose surveillance
coverage, we stop playing.
If we have no camera
coverage to the games,
we just pull the lids up, lock
the games, and wait it out.
We wouldn't deal the games
or operate without surveillance coverage.
The system's in lockdown.
All calls in and out of
this room are secure.
Again, sir, it's in lockdown.
It's a very Hollywood scene
that is completely unrealistic
for a multitude of reasons.
First of all, their surveillance room
looks like an NSA SCIF.
It's the nicest room I've ever seen,
and no surveillance room
I've been in is that nice.
They're not controlled by computers,
where you could be locked out
and couldn't make a phone call.
I don't think there's a scenario
where we would be stuck in a room.
I would hope that there's
some government agency
like OSHA who would protect us
from being locked in a room.
As a business practice,
we would have a hard-line
phone in every office,
and surveillance would
always be able to use that.
Obviously, if power went
out, that may go out with it,
and then we'd have to
use the old-fashioned
find the person and tell
them what's going on.
Whoa!
Bringing in dice has happened.
I haven't seen it in my career,
but I've heard stories in that
time frame of it happening.
And they wouldn't be magnetic.
They would be loaded, where
you would add some weight
to one side or another,
or you would shave some corners.
This is very Hollywood. The whole lighter
and seeing it flip so slowly
from one side to another.
I would hope my supervisors
would catch that
right away if it was possible.
And they wouldn't get away
with a whole lot of money,
because it's pretty obvious.
Getting that amount of
bets for the numbers
that they kind of had
over everybody's heads,
apparently there's no table
maximum on any of these games,
which is unrealistic as well.
I think I saw a $100,000
bet on a snake eyes,
which, I think $500's
about the most I've seen
as a limit for that.
Every bet on every table
has a maximum-amount bet.
All very, very unlikely and comical.
For accuracy of casinos,
I rate it about a 2.
I would love to know if
a mathematician out there
ever looked at any of
those equations on there
and figured out if it was anything.
Card counting is not some
extravagant trigonometry problem.
It's just basic counting.
Second of all, you really can't learn
card counting in one day, reading a book.
The general public knowing about it
has probably been a boon for us,
because people think they
can come out and do it,
and they really can't.
[screaming]
If you're going to count
cards, you probably wouldn't
attract that much attention to yourself.
You have the character in the background
flipping off the cameras,
creating a lot of energy around
and drawing attention to themselves.
Splitting fives.
Noticing that they're doing things, again.
He did split fives,
which you would never do,
even if you were a card counter.
You would have to maybe
know what the next three
or four cards coming out of the shoe were
to make that make sense.
He can't lose! He can't lose!
The floor supervisor and the pit boss
talking to each other.
We wouldn't need to cover
our mouths with a clipboard.
They're not going to read our lips.
It would be, "Hey, something's
going on over there.
We're watching it on camera.
Let's make a plan for what
we're going to do about it."
[screaming]
Doing a distraction to escape
doesn't make any sense,
'cause they still have
to cash the chips out.
Counting cards is not illegal,
unless you're using some device
to give yourself an advantage.
Smartwatch or a computer in
your shoe or on your thigh,
that would make it cheating a game.
But keeping track in your head
and knowing how many big
cards versus little cards are,
you can gain an advantage,
and so it's frowned upon.
If somebody's card-counting
in a Las Vegas casino,
we simply say, "Hey, you're not welcome
to play blackjack anymore.
Your action's too good for us."
This scene, not very
realistic in that regard.
1 for accuracy of how
we do things in a casino
or representing how
card counters would act.
Ace: Cash flows from
the tables to our boxes,
through the cage,
and into the most sacred room
in the casino, the count room.
It's not realistic to a modern casino
as far as how you would
enter it, how it's laid out,
or how the actions are
actually taking place.
You see the keep-out sign,
and then they walk in.
We wouldn't allow anybody to walk in
with a briefcase nowadays.
The workers that walk in are walking in
with clear purses, if at all.
The count room is the most
secure room in the building.
There are procedures in
place for who can go in,
how they can go in, what they
can do when they're there.
Probably in part because
these things did happen
when they were run by
individuals or by the mob,
versus now, publicly traded companies.
Nicky: They're counting
money. Who wants to bother?
And the best part was that
upstairs, the board of directors
didn't know what the f--- was going on.
I mean, to them, everything
looked on the up and up.
But when you're paying out at the cage,
we would count by hand.
And they did a good job of
how their hand motions were
and how they laid the bills out.
Every table, there's a paddle
to the right of the dealer,
and they take the cash, and
they drop it into a slot,
and it goes into what's called a drop box.
And those are collected daily,
and they're double-lock-secured.
And security would come
around and remove them,
take them into the count room,
where it's unlocked and the money is just
dropped out onto a clear table.
And then the money is counted
and sorted and assigned to that table.
Nicky: The guys inside the counting room
were all slipped in there
to skim the joint dry.
They'd do short counts,
they'd lose fill slips,
they'd even take cash right
out of the drop boxes.
It's in a time period, back in the day,
where you hear stories
about these things going on.
A fill slip is just an order form
when a table game needs more chips.
Throughout the day, as
people get up and walk away
and cash out, we have to
replenish those chips.
And you order a fill from the cage
to bring more chips to the table.
And that's how you figure out
how much a table wins
or loses in a given day.
Nicky: And it was up to
this guy, right here,
standing in front of about $2 million,
to skim the cash off the top
without anybody getting
wise, the IRS or anybody.
The skim was apparently a real thing
that the mob was doing to the casinos.
Casinos are big business, so
it takes a lot of employees
to factor in the cash that comes through
and the accounting paperwork
that goes along with that.
So it is a very busy room,
there's a lot of people working,
but not busy enough
that we wouldn't notice
somebody walking in with a briefcase
and walking out with the cash.
It takes key access,
and there's also cameras
everywhere nowadays.
Ace: You can spot these a--holes
by watching the way they bet.
Like this guy.
He's betting lavender chips at $500 each
with only one little problem.
He's always guessed right.
When things stand out, you
take a closer look at it.
So they did a great job of
how the dealers are moving,
how they're paying, how
they're putting cards
on the tables, to how the
supervisors stand in the pit,
to even how De Niro's character
walked in and started to observe things.
Ace: I saw that the dealer was weak,
but he wasn't in on it.
He just wasn't protecting his hand.
He was lifting his hole card way too high.
The first thing he noticed was
that the guy always guesses right.
Kind of bends down to tie his shoe
so he can get a look at what's going on
and where those angles are coming from
and figures out that there's
a cheater on the other side.
Ace: Signaling his buddy.
They cruise from casino to
casino looking for weak dealers
the way lions look for weak antelope.
Using a device to cheat, at
least in the state of Nevada,
is a crime, so you don't
see that nearly as often.
Things like that used to happen
as computer technology took hold.
If it wasn't for the device,
they wouldn't really be
doing anything wrong,
just taking advantage of a weak dealer.
Those were the way we used
to check the hole card,
was for them to cover
it up and look for it.
Nowadays we have a thing
called a peeker device,
which is a two-way mirror
that they slide the cards right into
so that there's no risk of
exposing that card anymore.
Ace: Turns out this guy
and his f---ing pals,
they were knocking this
place dead for years.
I've heard a lot of stories.
I've never heard of a cattle prod.
There are stories of back
rooms without cameras
where guys get roughed up a little bit.
Nowadays, we don't need to do that.
We have the Nevada Gaming Control Board,
we have security,
where we would just notify
and do everything through a legal process.
It's once they brought
that device into play.
And we'd notify the gaming commission,
say, "Hey, we have somebody
that we suspect of cheating."
And we would hand it right off to them.
I think the movie was done incredibly well
from a technical standpoint.
Everything outside of the cattle prod.
That knocks the clip down to about a 7½.
Charlene: Oh, my God, I can feel a kick!
Shelly: F---ing amateurs.
This is a more realistic thing
that could happen and has happened.
It's switching out dice.
Fake dice, incredibly uncommon.
Alec Baldwin's character
coming up as the casino boss,
somebody with the experience
to be able to see,
hey, the way he's cupping his
hand when he picks them up,
or the way he's releasing them
where fingers are bent up
to try and hide something.
We have policies for that too.
When a shooter shoots,
the supervisor's looking
for their hand to be open to make sure
they're not hiding dice in there.
Cheating on dice can be common
because there's a lot going on.
There's a lot of players,
there's a lot of distraction.
The biggest cheating scam that happens
is what's called dice sliding,
where you would set one dice to a number,
and then when you go to throw them,
instead of the dice tumbling
and becoming a random result,
they can control one or both of the dice
and know what the outcome is
and either bet with it or against it.
It takes a crew of people.
Someone to distract the dealer,
someone to throw it, another
one to make a big bet.
So a couple times a year
you hear of a casino
getting hit with a dice-sliding team.
Again, we have policies
and procedures in place
that protect us from that.
They always have serial numbers on them.
We make sure that they match
and that they're our dice.
There is some security built into it.
Yeah, he's up $18,000 since
I stepped up to the table.
Sorry, Shelly. I'm kind
of hit or miss these days.
In the scene, we see William
Macy acting as a cooler,
somebody who has such bad luck
that they put him at the table,
then his bad luck hopefully
rubs off on everybody else.
Unfortunately, it is a thing.
I haven't seen it in a long, long time.
Managers throwing salt under a table
or pennies under a table,
because somehow that
was equated to bad luck.
Modern casinos, I think, have
all gotten away from that
and just realized it's all about the math.
Let's get it, let's get it!
[everyone groaning]
Aw.
Guys, I thank you, my
pregnant wife thanks you.
When he sensed that he
was going to get caught,
he said, all right, the gig's up,
and he switched back to the original dice
and happened to seven out.
Using your pregnant wife as a distraction,
this is a much more
realistic version of cheating
than the "Ocean's Eleven"
scene with the magnetic dice.
Them switching out dice, I
think this is very accurate.
I'd rate it an 8.
I feel like you should
have somebody from the CIA
or FBI in here to evaluate
this, more than me,
because it doesn't pass
the smell test for me
on how casinos work
or anything that would happen in a casino.
I think they say in the movie
it connects three casinos
that in reality are a mile apart.
There's no secret bunker
anywhere with elevator in.
And then the two security guards
just happen to be facing
away from the only elevator,
facing a door for no reason.
Rusty: As your manager's
probably reporting to you now,
you have a little over $160
million in your vault tonight.
You may notice we're only
packing up about half that.
It would depend on how often
deposits are made to the bank
or whatever, but we are required
to be able to cover
any winners and losers.
Now, does that mean we have
to give it to them in cash?
No. We just write them a check for it.
Modern casinos, we've become
increasingly a cashless society,
and we have credit markers
and bank wire transfers.
Yen?
In previous clips, we saw
where the count room was.
And then once the money's counted,
it's put into a secure location.
You can call it a vault if you want to.
But it being this far out
of the way, this protected,
like it's holding the nuclear codes.
Benedict: Cue up the tape to the robbery.
Installed on Tuesday.
The images we saw of those
men robbing us was a tape.
Walsh: What?
I feel safe to say that nobody has a vault
quite like this one, or
would we spend the money
to inlay the marble, or
terrazzo, or whatever that was
with the name of the casino in the vault.
That seems like we could spend that money
better somewhere else.
I've worked at some
extravagant, opulent places,
but that's even a little bit over the top.
Our directors of security,
our security managers
all either were former law
enforcement or know them,
so they would know when
these guys walked in.
The likelihood of an
entire team of criminals
pretending to be Las Vegas
Metro or SWAT or whoever
and walking out with money,
I had a hard time watching this movie
when I watched it the first time.
And I'm like, wow, I really have to
suspend reality to enjoy this.
A 1 on how things in a real casino look
or act or are run.
Cameras generally aren't at eye level
where you could spray-paint them.
They're usually up in the ceiling.
First thought is, that's probably the most
unsecure count room and
vault in any casino anywhere.
Those look like regular office doors
and the locks that are on
my garage or back door,
as opposed to the locks that we would use.
How the casino's laid out,
it's not very realistic.
The count room is generally
pretty far back of house,
where it would take a couple of layers,
couple of access points
for someone to get to.
There wouldn't necessarily need to be
a security guard in or
in front of that door.
There are security everywhere
at the access points to
the back of the house
that would take to get to that
hallway, to get to that door.
I'm only going to say this once, OK?
Who's listening?
I am, yeah.
What we would wear in the count room
is overalls with no pockets,
so that there was no ability
for anybody to hide
cash, chips, or anything.
You would wear that uniform into the room
and not bring bags or anything with you,
so that you couldn't take
anything out of the room.
Main booth, scramble security.
Call Vegas PD. We need backup.
While surveillance did notice
them after a few seconds
in the count room, they
would've noticed them
in the back of house, on
their way to the count room,
before that ever happened.
Somebody's always watching.
Obviously, once they did notice them,
they said notify metro, which
is exactly what we would do.
Freeze! Hold it right there!
I would tell the security team,
and I think they would say the same,
we wouldn't engage on the casino
floor and risk a shoot-out.
Not a wise idea.
Let them get away with the
money, and we'll use our cameras,
and we'll use metro, and
we'll track them down.
We usually can see the getaway
car, see the license plate.
There has been some large thefts
throughout history of cages.
And they are very usually
low-tech smash-and-grab hold-ups.
And I've yet to hear of
anybody getting away with it.
Armed robbery, that's more
realistic to what I've seen.
But overall, I'd say it rates about a 5.
Professionals always place
their bets through the croupier.
Croupier: Two, six, 13.
Man: Two, six, 13.
Croupier is a term we
don't use in the states.
It's a European term for a dealer.
He's obviously dealing
European or French roulette,
based on some of the bets that were made.
No more bets, thank you.
34 red.
No, I'm sorry, sir, that's a late bet.
How the player cheated is a normal move.
It's called past posting.
The dealer catches the past post,
but it's interesting how he caught it,
because he was staring
into the wheel head,
which is what we train them not to do.
They should be watching the
layout for those past posts
and listening for the ball to
drop, and then glancing in.
He would've had to have
memorized every bet on the table
to notice that that was a late bet.
Is there a problem?
Yes, this croupier's
accusing me of cheating!
I want to be paid!
Pay the gentleman. In full.
When he does notice, the
supervisor comes over
and gets involved and
asks what's going on.
The gentleman acts aggressively.
We probably wouldn't pay that bet.
We would use surveillance to
see that there was a late bet.
Let's just get this guy
away from the table.
Let's go ahead and pay him
knowing we still have to cash him out,
so we still have the ability
to recoup those funds.
It's fairly realistic, from
the terminology they use
to the motions of the dealer
to how the dealer's dressed.
I rate this about an 8.
My favorite casino-heist
movie is definitely "Casino."
I think, by far and away, "Casino"'s
the most realistic interpretation
of what was done at that time
and how we've evolved to the modern time.
If you enjoyed this
video, click for another.